[Music]  Coney Island 1950s the beach the  boardwalk  I work here on day seven enter Carolina  excuse me  two of Jenny's here I'm Jenny I'm pumped  he's daughter  here's wife is he gonna be surprised I  marked Thank You Kelly  that's what you get when you marry a  gangster I gotta have a drink no you've  been good this can't be out here right  now we're expecting lightning storms  when you're married to a man who got  rich putting people's feet in cement you  probably never had to do a dish wife  don't like to go fishing anymore huh she  made like she liked it you get me on the  hook I was the fish  you know she's a marked woman should she  move on I know where all the bodies were  buried did he kiss you why are you  getting so heated I'm gonna find his  pageant everything's coming apart you  look a little crazy to me when it comes  to love we often turn out to be our own  worst enemy  I know what it is you did don't you  think you're being a little melodramatic  [Music]  you